[Musik]
schreibt mal bitte kurz den Chat was ich
machen soll sollen wir
erstmal zum Außenposten da hinten noch
mal hin
weil ich glaube da war nichts mehr oder
oder sollen wir irgendwie mal versuchen
das Portal anzuzünden was sind denn was
für was sind denn diese leuchtenden
Tiere dahinten ich hatte ein paar
Kommentare gelesen ähm aber wofür
brauche ich die denn das sind Helfer die
leuchtenden Dinge tun Items einsammeln
ey ganz kurz verarscht mich mal bitte
nicht könnt ihr mir weh tun soll ich
noch mal den Jump machen da hinten soll
ich springe gesagt schnell Bescheid
vielleicht bin ich da ich habe ein
bisschen Stream Verzögerung das sollte
so 10 Sekunden das ist bei euch
angekommen ist sag Bescheid so springen
ich weiß nicht ich springe scheiß drauf
für euch komm junge
[Musik]
ich schaffe das habe Liebe
Digger wie lang ist das denn das kam mir
gar nicht sondern vor dass sie aber auch
total Lust ich wollte mich jetzt so da
hoch weil das war richtig dumm
runterlaufen können
oh mein Gott
nein das ist doch nicht Wahr
Digger ist das euer ernst
ey was mache ich denn jetzt warum sind
denn hier so viele was soll ich tun sie
und lauf schnell
[Musik]
ich laufe erstmal zu den
ich habe ein halbes Herz
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
ich hör nur von jeder Seite habe ich ein
Pfeil im Kopf
so ich lasse jetzt frei Leute wenn mich
irgendwer von euch verarscht hat ne dass
sie hier nicht dass sie nicht freundlich
sind wenn ihr mich jetzt angreifen
[Musik]
komm kleiner Mann ach lol das ist auch
Erde fällt mir gerade auf das ist ja ach
jetzt habe ich kein Eimer mit ich
überlege gerade ob ich es riskiere die
Erde einfach so abzubauen ohne einen
Eimer zu holen weil wenn ich mich dann
im Eimer runter Bau wenn mich einer
einmal einmal einer einmal einer dann
brauche ich das jetzt so ab
hier vorne rein
komplett aus Rückschläge passieren aber
man kommt in Verstärker zurück du
Arschloch okay weiter wir schauen uns an
was ich momentan heute hat eine Erde
okay 48 Pfeile ist ärgerlich ich gehe
gleich sofort untereinander ich muss nur
einmal wirklich kurz von euch wissen wie
ich das mache mit dem Holzblock schreib
mal eins in den Chat ob er hier hin muss
und dann hier anzünden zwei in den Chat
wenn er hier hin muss also hier vor oder
ja wenn möglich oder ob er auf diese
Höhe muss dass er hier mit auf einer
höher ist also eins zwei oder hier drei
habe ich gerade eine Katze gehört
habt ihr auch gerade einen miau gehört
nein ich finde es voll cool diese ganzen
Begriffe zu sagen Mods Chat pogas Twitch
aber ich habe keinen Bock dass ein
Straße die Leute fragen
was steht für ein komischer Typ hier ein
laber rein dann fängt das Ding an zu
brennen und dann geht's aufs Portal
drüber wir können ja eh nicht viel
verlieren glaube ich ne das sollte schon
klappen sind die Jahre später das klappt
so nie was machst du hey ich frage euch
ob das so geht und jetzt sagt ihr alles
klappt nicht oder was was für Lava und
das Holz wo soll denn hier eine Lava und
das Holz okay wir schauen uns das jetzt
bei Youtube an warte
ich frage euch nie wieder jeder weiß
wahrscheinlich
nein bist du nicht ich dachte weil der
Name dein Name fängt auch mit m an warum
macht man sowas oder Portal stellt man
einfach zwei Holz auf ich war ja
komplett auf dem falschen Weg wegen euch
nicht weil ich falsch verstanden habe
weil ihr einfach nicht schreiben könnt
schaut mal jetzt wir lassen das mal kurz
hier so laufen ich habe noch mal kurz
das Video von dem zu ändern
und das Portal somit aktivieren
[Musik]
hör dir das was ich höre wenn dieser Typ
mir mehr beibringen konnte in einer
Minute in der das Video geht als ihr
Idioten wenn ich jetzt hier drauf drücke
und das Portal ist an ihr werdet alle
blockiert
[Musik]
wir gehen rein in die Hölle ich bin
gespannt wie es aussieht ich gucke noch
nicht ihr dürft als erstes gucken
ich tippe
[Musik]
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es
nur normale Hölle ist ich tippe das da
auch dass das nur eine kleine Insel ist
gar nichts gesehen
[Musik]
leute das ist ein anderes Portal
das ist noch ein Portal
oder liege ich falsch wenn ich das
Portal anzünde komme ich dann
in eine andere Welt wieder komme ich
woanders raus ich schaue mal in die
Kiste
Leute was ist denn eine Feuerkugel du
kannst das Portal mit dem Feuer charge
an können anzünden ich kann es auch so
anzünden oder weil ich will das Ding
jetzt nicht verbrauchen also ja ich kann
damit rechts ich glaube ich machen das
ist so ein Feuerball der dann
rausgeflogen kommt dann geht das Portal
an oder ist auch noch Gold soll ich das
Gott Leute soll ich das Gold nehmen und
für die Dings verwenden
für eine Rüstung selber nachdenken über
deinen dummen Fragen du kannst Gold mit
Stein nicht abbauen boah ey ich hätte
wirklich mit Stangen gerade abgebaut was
kannst du eigentlich guck mal das Portal
an Leute ich gehe einfach rein
ich bin gespannt
ich will aber trotzdem noch im never
bisschen rumlaufen
oder
sind da dann Blaze rods drin
geht das überhaupt weil da müsste ja
dann Spawner auch sein ne
[Musik]
auf jeden Fall jetzt nur Glowstone okay
es geht aber auch noch weiter runter
stehen okay das können wir einfach
mitnehmen
was sind das dann kamen sieben Pilze ne
da Warzen genau sage ich ja gut dann
haben wir das ja eigentlich fertig
erledigt oder ich dachte jetzt hier sind
auch play Stores oder so das wäre ganz
geil gewesen oder was
nee auch nicht
das ist drauf
[Musik]
Leute bin ich gerade dumm
das ist das endportal ich gehe da nicht
rein auf gar keinen Fall gehe ich da
rein ich bin noch überhaupt nicht
ausrüstig wird direkt sterben vom
enderdragon aber geil das hier das Ende
ist das war's wir haben eine Menge
geschafft wir waren in meinem
Außenposten sieht man jetzt gar nicht
mehr wegen dem blöden regen wir haben
das Portal angezündet bekommen wir haben
ein bisschen hier aufgeräumt wir haben
hier den See abgebaut da könnt ihr mir
gerne mal ähm dann hier in dem Highlight
Video das kommt auch auf YouTube in die
Kommentare schreiben was ich hier
vielleicht hinbauen soll wir haben äh
dem Netherland Besuch abgestattet wir
sind gestorben dahin also auch ein
bisschen schade allerdings haben wir
auch im nett einiges entdeckt eine sehr
sehr gelungene sehr sehr gelungener
Skyblock Stream auf jeden Fall mich
freut dass ihr euch das Video bisschen
angeschaut hat wenn es euch gefallen hat
das gerne Daumen hoch unter dem Video da
abonniert den Kanal und klickt
selbstverständlich auf die Glocke um
weitere Videos hier vom Skyblock nichts
verpassen ich weiß noch nicht genau wann
der nächste Skyblock Stream kommt aber
ich halte dich auf dem Laufenden folgt
mir am besten auf Twitch heißt der Laser
Luca oder auf Instagram da werde ich
nämlich auch immer sagen wenn ich live
bin und dann könnt ihr
Benachrichtigungen anmachen und dann
läuft der Hase ganz ganz schnell läuft
er dann so wir hören uns sehen uns haut
rein ciao
[Musik]